hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
today I'm just gonna be sharing with you
part two of the talk--i did for the
creative writing group so this one is
all about focus concentration flow
States avoiding writer's block hopefully
this is something some of you will find
interesting a few people had asked me to
do a video on concentration and that is
something I'm going to be delving into
in more detail in future but for now
hopefully you can glean something from
this so yeah the format is a bit
different from my usual video here but
don't worry I've got more of the usual
videos on the way I'm doing a workout
video based on arrow I'm doing a big
video on nootropics and in fact going
forward I'm going to be taking every
single Monday off for the coming weeks
in order to focus purely on the pioneers
so there should be a lot of cool stuff
on the way please subscribe if you'd
like to be involved with that thanks a
ton for watching as always and I'll see
you next time bye for now
yes I was thinking now I'd go on and
talk a little bit about how I maintain
my high output because I think that's
something people were slightly
interested in because maybe some of you
struggled to find the time to do the
writing that you want to do so yeah I I
could say I currently write ten to
thirty thousand words a day that was a
rare thing normally ten thousand I was
writing 10,000 words a day and then I
had the option to write to work with
Android Authority and instead of doing
the sensible thing and cutting my work
in half I decided that I would do that
as well until 1:00 p.m. and then I did
my 10,000 words in the four remaining
hours of the day which was ambitious but
it's so far worked out I'm kind of
burning out I'm going to take Monday's
off in future to just work on my own
projects and then hopefully that will
help me to take off there but yes so
there's a few things I've found useful
to this end one of them is I always work
in cafes I don't know if anyone else
does that I think it would be an even
more romantic image for a creative
writer rather than coffee right - but I
like the idea of sitting in a cafe yeah
are there students and there's also
people like me I was in the bodily in
library in aqsa death then as a sign
saying no laptops allowed because yes
some people like you because you'd go
there on a regular basis and you buy
lots of coffee and some people hate you
because you take up their seat so I
think it depends on how busy they are I
recently moved to Vista out of London
and it's a bit harder to find coffee
shops there but if you can go to coffee
shop it's so much better for
concentration like if you're struggling
to find the motivation in the evening
for half an hour to write a chapter of
your book whatever then that would be a
really good stop off on the way home
you've got a good laptop sitting there
with a coffee because you've got no
distractions because obviously I work
from home otherwise permanently and it
can be and if I don't work then I don't
get paid so I really need to not be you
know watching TV or playing computer
games and so go into a coffee shop helps
me to do that and even because I can
obviously play computer games on my
laptop but you feel self-conscious if
someone looks over your shoulder and
they're like a guy who's just sat there
for three hours playing games on his
laptop so so that really helps and also
the noise in the background is actually
quite useful in the background chatter
because that becomes like
noise as long as you don't accidentally
overhear a really interesting
conversation does yeah I've heard I've
had heard people breaking up I've heard
I mean that would be good for
inspiration for creative writers
breaking up interviews yeah all sorts of
things and I always watch the interviews
and thing I'm so glad I'm not you get a
bit of schadenfreude to there but yeah
in general normally it just becomes a
kind of background chatter and that's
really useful for drowning out
everything else and another tip you can
use for that same effect is to put on
headphones obviously with noise
cancelling ideally but play a single
album or a few tracks that you like and
have them on repeat and this is a
something that apparently Matt Mullenweg
or Mullenweg I'm not sure I said he's
the creator of WordPress and he said he
uses this when coding and the reason
that's effective is because it's got the
beat and it kind of keeps you awake and
interested but at the same time because
it's repeating over and over you're you
eventually become desensitized to it you
kind of tune it out becomes like the
ticking of a clock and so if the only
thing you can hear is something you've
tuned out you've actually it's kind of
like sensory deprivation you now don't
have as far as your brain is away you've
got nothing coming in through your ears
and some of my most like focused moments
have been doing that when I've really
got to work I put on one album which is
rocky for Vance the cola the the synth
the synth it's and I just listen to that
on repeat and then I can focus without
kind of any distraction as long as you
know it's not something too exciting
going on in the coffee shop but that's
yeah a tip you can use another one I
find quite useful and I don't know this
could apply to you guys when I have to
write something the next day and I know
what it is I'll often start it just a
tiny bit before I end the day and so
that kind of goes against conventional
wisdom because they tend to say you know
people tend to assume you should try and
finish everything at the end of the day
but if you leave something unfinished
it's kind of human nature to feel a bit
itchy and uncomfortable about that you
want it finished so tends to be that
when you then go and sit down the first
thing you'll do is just finish that
thing because you know it's open and
it's and it's going I find that quite
effective especially for something I
don't want to write and also
psychologically if I've so often my
orders are broken down into sir kind of
I'll have to do 10 blah
pays 400 words and that sounds like a
lot less 4,000 words but if I do three
of them then that's seven blog posts
which is you know just over half of them
left and I can kind of talk it through
in my head it seems like easier and it
tends to go so much faster when you
think of it as easier versus when you
think of it as a there's a big kind of
wall that you've got to complete in that
sense Hemingway he wrote he always said
that that was one of his best tips was
always finish where you kind of know
he's got you know what the next lines
gonna be in the next kind of bit so that
you don't have to wake up and start with
the blank page yes yes okay I didn't
know he did that as well he also wrote
standing up Denis Hemingway I think so
yeah so you know get their standing
desks now and they say that's good for
creativity etc yeah that really wouldn't
work for me I think because I I get so
focused I need to be set down but I
think if you're if you're not chasing
word-count and perhaps that would be a
more effective way definitely getting up
and taking breaks in between and giving
yourself the breaks is super important
that's something that I have to do
because obviously I in theory can earn
like a unlimited amount by just not
sleeping or socializing so you have to
be quite strict with yourself and say
this is the time off and that makes a
massive difference when you then go back
into it the next day because if you then
give yourself a time off then yeah you
you won't be recharged you'll kind of be
burned out as he has he'll even start I
drink a lot of coffee to get through and
that's not ideal really because you know
this is increasing dopamine and
adrenaline etc and you can easily reach
adrenal fatigue especially we've got a
huge workload
you're just working as hard and as fast
as you can and you don't take the break
you know eventually you can keep it for
a couple of days and then you start to
feel the burn out that's when you get
ill and then that's when your
productivity really does suffer but I
don't imagine that's a problem a lot of
people have with creative writing
probably yeah well that's
you know you start to get more more
tight but you ignore it yeah
I'm in this book where you do wonder
it's like what can I come up with a
single sentence now that makes sense and
it's like yeah yes a reminder actually
that it made the water noise it's like a
kind of like a noise like the water
feeling up every once in a while
yeah but talking what hanging actually
anything used to say that you had to lie
down it didn't matter how you would do
the research first and you like that you
rested well lying down they say is is
good for um if you're in a more supine
position it's better for creativity
because because when you're very focused
and very stressed creativity actually
goes down you release more dopamine and
adrenaline etc you get a kind of tunnel
vision and obviously the purpose of that
from an evolutionary perspective is to
avoid danger etc and run away or worse
when you're relaxed you have a more your
your brain is allowed to wander so you
have all and they say there's no such
thing as creativity it's just the
combination of two existing ideas so
obviously the more you relax and the
more your mind wanders the more likely
you are to you know see two disparate
ideas and then connect them and that way
creativity happens so actually the more
wired you are and the more focused you
actually can lose creativity so a lot of
people will take you know kind of
amphetamine type things to try and boost
their productivity they actually might
be losing a bit of creativity in the
process so yeah it kind of makes sense
and it could it almost make sense to
kind of split your creative thinking and
you're like output almost so that you
come up with the ideas when you relaxed
and then you output it later on because
another tip i have for avoiding writer's
block is sometimes i know i'm going to
be struggling with a topic not just
because i don't know the subject but
because i've got no interest in it or no
angle so I'll kind of write it in my
head when I'm not sat down so that when
I come to write it I'm ready kind of
thing say if I'm walking somewhere or if
I'm sleeping or driving our thing you
know what's the angle how will I open it
well my opening line be what's the rough
structure and the conclusion and then if
you come up with that idea as you're
kind of moving around and and traveling
what have you then when you sit down to
actually write it it's already there and
you don't have that kind of no blank
Paige kind of feeling and that can
definitely help I would imagine with
creative writing as well and there's
something else kind of related is that
if it's a really dull topic that I just
have no interest in writing I always try
and come up with a way to that that's
when you tend to get writer's block
because it's not interesting to you so
I'll come up with a way to make it
interesting to myself so for instance if
it's something like car windshields like
which I did have to write about when I
started out that's the most boring you
know four car windshield companies I
guess auto glass replace type thing so
what I would do is I'd like to think
about the time that my windshield got
cracked and then write a kind of
personal account of that or I'd write
about say some other aspect of a long
journey that I find more interesting
like car sickness because that kind of
relates to my interested in health etc
and it's all it's kind of still linked
and still okay as far as the client is
concerned as long as you think it back
to what they're selling but it's
something I find more interesting and I
know that that's a tip that some
creative writers follow as well because
say you're really stuck and you've been
stuck on this scene that you don't want
to write then often they say that
actually the reason you don't to write
it is because you find it boring and
like it's just it's it might be an
exposition scene or it might be just
really dull scene and it's like if
you're too bored to write it and that
doesn't bode very well for the readers
so actually instead of trying to force
yourself through it what you should do
is try and reframe it so you're excited
to write it you know whether that means
basing this on a moving train or
something and they're on the roof I
don't know but you know just instead of
forcing yourself say maybe the problem
is that is the project and that needs to
be more interesting because what you
were describing about not going to
toilet and stuff they would call that a
flow State ironically so a flow state is
when you also focused on something that
you're you go into that tunnel vision
and they say that actually
neurologically it's called temporal
hypofrontality which means that your
prefrontal cortex the planning and the
the anxiety part of your brain is
actually closed down you've gone to a
pure center kind of response I don't
know fully how that works because
obviously if you're writing you would
need your planning aspect but they say
that it's the same thing and it's the
same thing as when you're like
snowboarding or when something falls out
you're covered
catch it really quickly or in your
common conversation and you forget how
long you've been talking for because you
say fascinated it's always just doing
drugs yeah they want to eliminate some
of that other noise and just yeah into
flow which I'm not advocating but yeah
but you know I mean Hemingway said right
drunk it's you know which doesn't mean
you have to be drunk but just figuring
out when when is it that you're in that
state you know whether it's walking down
the street and you're just kind of yeah
and no because you're paying attention
you know and finding when that zone yeah
exactly and there are obviously non-drug
ways that you can achieve similar sort
of things I think Tim Ferriss drinks
yerba map to T or yerba mate and how you
say it but that contains caffeine and
l-theanine and I think Theo bromine and
Darwin drank that and he apparently
called it the world's most perfect
stimulant and that's pretty long yeah so
the are feeling takes yeah it's this
auto sensor feature yes so that like
makes you less anxious etc while still
having ly stimulatory effect so these
are called nootropics there's a whole
extra subject that you can use to
increase your focus but you haven't very
careful because some of them are not
good my advice
exactly and it can it can cause
permanent changes in the brain a lot of
them have claimed to have no side
effects but I wouldn't always take out
with a pinch of salt but my advice for
something like that would be just
nutrition you know eating a lot of these
nootropics turn out to just be basic
things you can get in your diet anyways
like for instance the lutein is found in
carrots and things and that's been shown
recently to increase your retention of
ideas and like you don't lead and
between b6 and b12 good for energy and
you know all these things so if you just
eat a good nutritious meal that will
actually provide you with the energy and
the building blocks that your brain
needs and I mean a lot of these
neurotransmitters I'm talking about they
are produced by various different
vitamins etc that's what they're made
out of so you don't need to be buying
anything off the internet you can just
eat well you know smoothies etc
and something we were talking about I
said a lot of people say they don't have
time to write or they don't have time to
build their own business etcetera but I
find it doesn't tend to come down to
time it tends to come much more down to
energy so you actually have the time you
get home in the evenings but you just
would rather watch TV or whatever and
that's just because you you're again
you're you're burned out so instead of
trying to make more time you should
focus on making more energy whether that
means being a little bit less stressed
at work or whether that means changing
the time of day you write so maybe in
the morning before you're tired out
yeah so and for me I'm always trying to
juggle the work I'm doing for these
clients with my own website which is
really what I want to grow and promote
over time and kind of it's very easy
after you've spent a whole day writing
that number of words to not want to do
the next bit so I need to like make sure
I leave a bit of energy in the tank or
do it first in the day and obviously I
like going to the gym as well I always
make sure I do that first because I feel
Eve it till the evening and it often
doesn't happen so yeah I would say
prioritize the few if you really want to
do the writing then prioritize it and
put it towards the start of the day
instead of towards the end or maybe even
you know say no to some other things
which could mean missing out on
opportunity or whatever but I guess you
can't do everything unfortunately
there's kind of point where you're you
know obviously filled the energy with
the right nutrition and sleep etc but
then as well make sure you give yourself
a time in the day where you do have that
energy and you're ready to work and know
yourself in that regard as well so yeah
and obviously something else that can
help is the right hardware and for me I
use a mechanical keyboard with cherry
blue MX switches and I recently upgraded
this and I've done my research and
apparently can help to reduce RSI and
it's more satisfying to type on and so
this is the keyboard but the switch
means that when you press the button
down it it kind of clicks more instead
of just bottoming out yes it is like the
Oscar ones yeah and they say that's
better for writer and that switch in
particular they say is the writer switch
is really loud and clicky so if you plan
to write at night it's not terribly
effective and I have a wider monitor now
which they say can boost productivity by
30%
I'm not sure about that but if you are
researching it's very useful to be able
have potentially three windows open like
what you're writing your notes and then
you know the website that you're
researching from at the same time for in
the coffee shops I use a surface pro
which is really useful because you can
carry it around it's very light etc I
also just got myself I did post images
of it all the time which I should be
getting paid for them and I've got a GPD
pocket recently which is a laptop this
kind of that big so you can literally
take it anywhere with you and write
wherever you are which i think is as
well a useful thing to be able to do
it's the GPD pocket and it's it's a it's
a Chinese brand I think and I found it
on Kickstarter now IndieGoGo so it's
kind of like it's not terribly
mainstream but you can buy it on Amazon
etc now but yeah it's a funny-looking
thing as well and I've got a little
folding keyboard I use as well for what
I really want to write something down
because you know as I saying as if you
walk around it's a good time to to come
up with ideas and if you're worried
you're gonna forget something and be
able to just jot it down quickly there's
always things I've actually been really
interested to try and find something
that I can write into and then have it
converted these things to exist smart
pens but I don't think any of them have
massively taken off yet oh yeah and it
have is it the one the screen at the
bottom oh yeah okay have you had to go
that's cool then well yeah
the yoga series things.you I like the
name Olivia yeah actually you send
writing by hand it kind of makes sense
as well because I think one more way to
potentially get into a flow state is to
get kind of immediate feedback that's
one of the reasons I like my keyboard is
because it creates lights and it has
that nice clicking noise yes
does he yes funny isn't it how something
like that can make a big difference to
how it feels to write but yeah because I
find when I'm programming or when I'm
video editing which I now the fair bit
for for Android Authority it's much
easier to get into that kind of flow
state where you forget to do other
things you forget to eat it cetera and I
think the reason for that is that you're
getting the immediate feedback of like
edit watch it back it's not right edit
watch it back in your think I'll just
one more little chunk and then it'll be
done the same with programming you kind
of try and fix a bug test it doesn't
work try it again test it doesn't work
so I think with writing I try and do
that as well that's one reason I was
trying to break it into small chunks in
my head so I can like write that off
that stone that's done and something
else I often do is like watch the word
count in particular and that's enough
I've been thinking of making as well as
do I try and make writing more like
gamified you know gamification is where
you get rewards and things that it feels
more rewarding to do it but yeah in
terms of like the focus and the dopamine
I think that's a good way of getting you
more yeah I think it really comes from
when you just really really love what
you're doing oh you found it really
interesting because like that's you
telling your brain like this is
important I need to focus kind of thing
it's not life or death but it is
something that's important to my
long-term goals so I guess it's just
like if you're not vocally love what
you're doing and if it's like a story or
topic that you're passionate about then
hopefully it should be relatively easier
to get into that state versus if it's
something that you're kind of forcing
yourself to do because you think need to
do it or because you've got a client who
is
obstinate